bonjour antoine bondage merci d'être
avec nous cet après midi sur rt france
alors on lisait à une situation
sanitaire et qui va mieux dans le hubei
et notamment à wuhan
comment peut-on l'expliquer tout
simplement alors il ya eu des mesures
extrêmement fortes vous leur a prié qui
ont été prises par les autorités
chinoises à partir du 23 janvier même si
on peut rappeler que des mesures
auraient peut-être pu être prise plus
tôt plus en amont de la crise en tout
cas les mesures prises à partir du 23
janvier déjà haoran ensuite dans le
groupe i puis dans l'ensemble du pays
ont permis non seulement de contenir la
majeure partie des cas dans la province
du hubei et ensuite progressivement au
fil des semaines
non seulement d'hospitaliser une grande
partie des malades et in fine est de
réduire au maximum l'épidémie on a
aujourd'hui plus de 75000 personnes qui
font remis de la maladie un peu plus de
3500 morts et encore 5000 personnes
malades dont 1500 en état grave
donc entre guillemets l'épidémie n'est
pas complètement fini même si li a très
peu de nouvelles infections et que ces
infections sont avant tout des cas
d'importation
il ne faut pas crier victoire trop vite
mais évidemment la chine a pu faire face
à cette épidémie la contenir et la gère
vous disiez à l'instant il ne faut pas
crier victoire trop vite
quelques cas sont encore présents dans
la région est ce que et c'est le bon
moment justement pour mettre fin à ces
mesures de restrictions de déplacements
alors ça ce sera aux épidémiologistes de
le dire si la décision est prise et
qu'il considère que le risque est
désormais limité même si la fin
définitive du confinement n'est pas
annoncée il faut le rappeler avant le 16
avril dans la ville de wau l'activité va
reprendre progressivement dans cette
ville il ya par contre une inquiétude
importante des autorités à pékin
les inquiétudes portent sur les quatre
d'importation d'où les mesures sans
précédent notamment la mise en
quarantaine de l'ensemble des personnes
qui arrivent à pékin et puis le risque
d'une seconde flambée épidémique
justement du fait de la fin de la
restriction de déplacement c'est quelque
chose que les autorités sanitaires
chinoises suivent étroitement et on le
voit par exemple en corée du sud il ne
faut jamais crier victoire trop vite
l'épidémie peut de façon limitée mais
peut tout de même repartir c'est un
risque un coco l'épidémie repartent
c'est possible c'est un risque qui est
pris en compte par les autorités
chinoises et qui est prise en compte
évidemment à l'étranger cela explique
notamment que la chine a fait en sorte
que l'ensemble des équipes médicales
étaient venus en soutien à mourad ne
rentrent pas tout dans leur province
deuxièmement cela explique aussi
pourquoi la chine continue de produire
massivement des équipements de
protection que ce soit des masques
évidemment des blouses des lunettes de
protection
la chine a considérablement accru ses
capacités de production ces dernières
semaines c'est d'ailleurs un modèle
qu'il faudrait peut-être reproduire en
europe afin de s'assurer que nos besoins
en termes d'équipements de protection
soit à cirer non seulement par nos
importations mais aussi par une
production nationale plus soutenue alors
on l'a dit on va pas crier victoire trop
vite en chine mais quelles pourraient
être les enseignements à tirer de cette
crise en chine pour les pays européens
qui sont en train de la vivre
alors il ya sûrement une enseignement en
main la crise et que la transparence
elle est indispensable quand il y à
l'émergence d'une épidémie afin non
seulement d'identifier les cas suspects
mais également de prendre des mesures de
sensibilisation puis peut-être de
confinement le plus rapidement possible
les autres mesures que qui ont été
prises en chine et qui nous donne un
enseignement important c'est que les
mesures de confinement et plus
généralement de restrictions de
déplacements de distanciation sociales
ont eu un impact considérable dans la
dans le fait de contenir puis de gérer
l'épidémie et c'est notamment ce qui
explique aujourd'hui qu'à l'étranger
dans l'ensemble des pays qui sont
durement affectés vous avez ces mesures
de distanciation sociale et de
restriction des déplacements et les
quelques enseignements aussi qu'il faut
tirer de la crise est là c'est à la
coopération internationale de le faire
et notamment
travers les échanges d'expérience c'est
que par exemple des traitements qui pond
qui ont pu faire l'objet d'essais
cliniques en chine pourrait et fond pour
certains déjà l'objet d'essais cliniques
en europe il a su entre nos sens
scientifique au delà même de toutes
contingences politiques il faut qu'il y
ait des échanges supplémentaire des
échanges renforcés afin le plus vite
possible dans l'ensemble des pays
pouvoir faire face à l'épidémie et
surtout pouvoir soigner au plus vite les
malades merci beaucoup antoine bombasse
d'avoir été avec nous cet après midi sur
rt france elle rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur à la fondation pour la
recherche stratégique et enseignant à
science pour merci beaucoup